Ryan Reynolds is here yeah find out this
era that's exciting enough but he's also
going to be premiering the unedited red
band trailer for the highly anticipated
film Deadpool
big deal now this one about to tell you
is absolutely true as a result of Ryan
Reynolds showing the Deadpool trailer
tonight on our show for the first time
ever I think in the whole history of the
time that I've been on television my
show has been given a tv-ma rating yes
there it is
[Applause]
that's never happen it's following me
it's like the dirty Roomba no this is
the first time it's ever happened it
means this of course tv-ma means for
mature audiences only
all right and let me explain that means
tonight's episode may contain crude
indecent language explicit nudity or
graphic violence that is what that means
we never had this freedom before yeah
in other words tonight
in other words ladies and gentlemen
tonight we can really cut loose it's
insane
oh absolutely you are so right Conan for
example instead of giving you the finger
throughout the entire monologue
underneath my lectern I can just do this
yeah
another thing that tv-ma rating allows
us for the first time ever all
bottomless camera men yes
looking good oh yeah all right cool and
now let's open up our directors
microphones you can hear how he really
directs the show every night check it
out okay cut to the dip shifts go to the
[Applause]
face and now back to Captain [ __ ]
calls me captain [ __ ]
and last but not least instead of rim
shots tonight we'll be using the much
more violent gun shot here we go hey
folks recently there's been growing
support for the CEO of Starbucks to run
for president yeah you thought the lines
of votes were long now
[Applause]
to get on the ballot hit need at least
10,000 misspelled signatures his
campaign promised every voter gets a
free Norah Jones CD his main goal is to
secure a single term but if that goes
well he'll aim for a double triple then
a quad with an extra shot I said extra
shot
[Applause]
and isn't this fun Annie I'd sure is
going
how about you Alan yeah it's real fun
hey how about the cameraman alright
[Applause]
wasn't that a great clip subscribe to my
youtube channel for an endless supply of
me
[Laughter]